حذر مهتمون في الساحه الثقافيه في مصر
مؤخرا وفي ظلال العلاقه الادبيه التي جمعت
ما بين نجيب محفوظ صاحب نوبل وسيد قطب
صاحب الظلال من مساعي جماعه الاخوان
لاختطاف ادب نجيب محفوظ وتحلق واتصال بين
قوسين مثقفي الاخوان باسمه جذور هذا
التوجه وبحسب بعض المثقفين المصريين ليست
جديده بل تعود الى نصيحه قدمها سيد قطب
لجمال النهري وهو ابن اخت نجيب محفوظ واحد
اعضاء الجماعه تتلخص في استماله نجيب
محفوظ ياتي هذا كله رغم التباس علاقه
الروائي نجيب محفوظ مع تيار الاسلامي بلغت
حد تكفيره كما في كتاب كلمتنا للشيخ عبد
الحميد كشك للرد على اولاد حارتنا او
محاوله اغتياله بناء على فتوى لزعيم
الجماعه الاسلاميه عمر عبد الرحمن
كانت علاقه محفوظ بقطب قد بدات عن طريق
لجنه النشر للجامعيين التي اسسها الشقيقان
عبد الحميد وسعيد جوده سحار عام
1943 بهدف ايجاد منفذ نشر للادباء الشبان
في تلك الفتره وكانت مهمه سيد في اللجنه
كتابه عروض نقديه لما يصدر من اعمال والذي
كان قد حقق موقعه في خريطه النقد الادبي
انذاك كتب قطب عن روايات نجيب محفوظ اربع
مرات في مجلات الرساله واحتفى به قائلا
نملك ان نقول اننا نسهم في تزويد المائده
العالميه في هذا الفن بلون خاص فيه الطابع
الانساني العام ولكن تفوح منه النكهه
المحليه وبالمقابل كتب عنه نجيب محفوظ في
ذات المجله ثلاث مرات
انتهت علاقه الرجلين تماما بعد ان زاره
نجيب محفوظ بعد خروجه من السجن بعفو صحي
عام
1964 قبل ان يعادي اعتقاله ويحكم عليه
بالاعدام وكان نجيب محفوظ اراد رصد منعطف
لسيد قطب الاخير بعين الاديب ووضعه امام
المرايا الروايه التي كتبها عام
1971 اي بعد خمس سنوات على اعدامه فاستلهم
نجيب محفوظ شخصيه قطب في فصل من فصولها
وقدمه باسم عبد الوهاب اسماعيل وقال انه
اليوم اسطوره وكالاسطوره تختلف فيه
التفاسير وبالرغم من انني لم القي منه الا
معامله كريمه اخويه الا انني لم ارتح ابدا
لسحنته ولا لنظره عينيه الجاحظتين
الحادتين وفيها جسد نجيب محفوظ ما تمناه
من عبد الوهاب اسماعيل او سيد قطب العوده
الى النقد الادبي ليرد عليه يالها من
تمنيات جاهليه فهل حقا يسعى مثقف لاخوان
الى اخت طاف اديب نوبل نجيب محفوظ وما
حقيقه انضمام ابناء شقيقته للجماعه انا
هدى الصالح وهذا برنامج جماعات بنناقش هذا
الموضوع مع ضيفنا من القاهره الدكتور محمد
سالم شوشه الروائي والناقد الاكاديمي حياك
الله معنا دكتور اهلا وسهلا
اسمح لي الله يسلمك استاذ محمد ابدا معاك
بهذا السؤال حضرتك حذرت في مقال سابق لك
من محاولات اختطاف الاخوان لاديب نوبل
نجيب محفوظ
ضمن محاولاتهم لاختطاف رموز ادبيه على اي
اساس بنيت هذا الاستنتاج وما تشوف انه
تهويل او مبالغه من قبل الباب
اولا يعني
هذا السلوك او الفعل للاختطاف
يمكن رؤيته في اطار استراتيجيه الاخوان
بشكل عام وتحولاتها ومنهجهم في التعامل مع
الرموز بصفه عامه
هناك شواهد وبلائل عديده
والهدف كان هو فكره
التحذير من مخطط شامل في التعامل مع
الثقافه بشكل عام لكن طبعا بحكم كون نجيب
شخصيه مركزيه وهو الاديب
العربي الاوحد الذي حصل على جائزه نوبل
وهو الاكثر
انتشارا ورواجا وترجعنا الى اللغات الاخرى
واكثر تاثيرا من حيث يعني حضور
اعمالي في السينما والوجدان العربي يعني
هناك دوافع كثيره
تدفعهم للتعامل مع نجيب محفوظ بشكل خاص
وبشكل مختلف
لمكانته الكبير
هناك استراتيجيه عامه
للاخوان في التعامل مع الثقافه والفكر
بشكل خاص وهذه الاستراتيجيه ليست جديده
يعني
الجهاز التثقيف او جناح التصقيف والطباعه
والفكر
نشا مع الاخوان من بدايتها كجماعه
فهذا الدور المرتبط بالتسقطيف
والنشا والتربيه والطباعه والكتب والجوانب
الفكريه قديم تمام لكنه يمر بمراحل
وبمنعطفات وبتحولات عديده بحسب يعني
تغيرات
السياقه المختلفه السياسيه
وسياقات المواجهه او
الانتشار او كونهم في السلطه او في
المعارضه يعني بحسب تغير موقع الجماعه او
اختلاف موقعه او ما يعرض لها من عوارض او
يعني حالات مختلفه فهناك استراتيجيه
استراتيجيه عامه مرتبطه
بالثقافه بشكل عام وبالتالي
لنجيب محفوظ بالضبط فاذا مجينا لنجيب
محفوظ بمركزيته ودوره
المحوري
ودوره تنوير
الذي يمثل خطرا على جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين فسنجد ان تماسات او تقاطعات او
او صدامات الاخوان معنى نجيب محفوظ عديده
يعني الموقف ليس ابن اللحظه الراهنه تسمح
لي يعني على اي اساس تم بناء هذا
الاستنتاج انا هون بالذات الحديث اليوم عن
اختطاف لادب نجيب محفوظ هل هناك ملامح
يعني في السنوات الاخيره
تم ملاحظتها او يعني
اكتشفتوها من النشاط الجماعه او مثقفين
اخوان الحقيقه اني في السنوات الاخيره
حصل
تركيز على
تعامل الاخوان النقدي مع ادب وابداع نجيب
محفوظ يعني الاختطاف لم يكن جديدا هو قديم
لكن حدث تحول في المرحله الاخيره باعتبار
ان الجماعه
في موقف هزيمه سياسيه بعد ثوره 30 يونيو
وبعد حركه الاصلاح والتحديث الكبيره في
الدول العربيه ورفض الجماعات وهزيمتها
وانحصارها في عدد من الدول فهم تحولوا الى
الوجه الناعم او الوجه الثقافي يعني هذا
الامر يجب ان يوضع في الاعتبار وهنا تغير
في السياق دفعهم لان يكونوا مختلفين في
تعاملهم مع نجيب محفوظ ما حدث هو التركيز
النقدي على نجيب محفوظ يعني صدرت عدد من
الدراسات الكثيره في السنوات الاخيره
للتعامل النقدي مع اعمال نجيب محفوظ وحتى
ندوات وترويض يعني اصبح هناك
خطاب يريد ان يقول اننا نحب الادب
ومنفتحون على الثقافه واننا
ليبراليون وانسانيون
ولسنا بالصوره النمطيه القديمه او
الكلاسيكيه او المضاده للادب والثقافه او
المحرمه للروايات
يعني ضمن ما حقق
الروائي والاديب المصري نجيب محفوظ من
شعبيه كاسحه في المجتمع المصري حتى باتا
رمز وطني ورمز قومي ايضا في مصر
فمن هذا الباب بدا اهتمام جماعه الاخوان
بالاعتناء بتراث الادبي
والروايات
وبكل ما يعني بكل مكتبته الادبيه ليش
الخوف من هذا الاهتمام اذا ربنا هدا
الاسلاميين او هذا جماعه الاخوان واصبحوا
يتابعون يعني
ويتذوقون الادب
الحقيقه ان التعامل مع الادب له قواعد
يعني قوانين واساسيات
هل تعامل جماعه الاخوان مع ابداع نجيب
محفوظ وتراث او ميراثه الابداعي وفق
الاطار الانساني والعالمي
والجمالي والمجدي ام انه من زاويه
ايدولوجيه
ويتجه لتحقيق اهداف اخوانيه معينه هذا هو
النسوان وهذا هو الافتراض الذي يجب ان
ننطلق منه في قراءتنا
لهذا التعامل الاخواني مع ابداع نجيب
محفوظ وتراثه الحقيقه ان هناك محطات
وعلامات
ويعني
رصد لسلوكيات مريبه وغريبه مثل مثل ماذا
مثل هناك مثلا قراءه شبه طائفيه الابداع
نجيب محفوظ يعني هناك انحراف عن الاهداف
الانسانيه النبيله ادلجت الادب يعني
يريدون ان يرى ابداع نجيب محفوظ وينظر
اليه من المنظور العقلي اخواني ومن منظور
اخواني بحث بمعنى يعني قراءه ادب نجيب
محفوظ بعقل اخواني او من نظاره اخوانيه
بالضبط هنا الخطر ما يمثل صحوه للعقل
يعني نقطه من نقاط التنوير يحيدونه
ويتجهون به او ياخذونه في مسارات مختلفه
تخدم استراتيجيه الاخوان وتخدم استراتيجيه
الجماعه على سبيل المثال هنلاقي انه مثلا
ياخذون ابدعوا في الاتجاه الثوري فقط تمام
يعني يركزون على الجوانب الثوريه حالات
الغضب يعني يركزوا على ما في هذا التراث
الروائي والابداعي من حالات الانتفاضه
والغضب بشكل مطلق دون ان يحبوا ان كان ان
هذا الغضب كان موجها ضد الاحتلال وضد مثلا
المعتدين على ثقافتنا وهو تحرر وطني اصلا
فهم يوحون هذه السياقات ويقدمون قراءتهم
الخاصه للثوره عند نجيب محفوظ ده على سبيل
المثال يعني بالضبط يعني حتى نضالي موجه
ومؤدد
برؤيه اخوانيه
هنلاقي برده كمان مثلا التصورات الدينيه
همم في همم رؤيتهم او نقضهم لابداع نجيب
محفوظ يعني
على سبيل المثال هناك كتاب صدر في الهيئه
المصريه العامه الكتاب في عام حكم الاخوان
في 2012 ابريل 2012 كتاب اسمه نجيب محفوظ
من الجماليه الى نوبل
مع الاسف يعني حتى هو كمان في كتاب لناقد
اخر شهير الدكتور
غالي شكري وهو الناقد مثلا مسيحي فهم
يلغون عنوان الكاتب الدكتور غالي شكري
وياتون بعنوان مثيل وكان صادر عن الهيئه
برده المهم ان في هذا الكتاب نجيب محفوظ
من الجماليه الى نوبل والذي اعده او او
كتبه مجموعه من المؤلفين يطرحون رؤيا
اخوانيه
وقراءه شبه طائفيه مثلا
فاحدهم مثلا يدرس الشخصيه المسلمه في ادب
نجيب محفوظ واحد ودراسه اخرى الشخصيه
المسيحيه في ادب نجيب محفوظ
وينسون ان هناك نسيج اسمه الشخصيه المصريه
يعني الاساس هي
حاضره عند نجيب محفوظ بوصفها شخصيه مصريه
وليس شخصيه مسلمه او شخصيه مسيحيه شو
التحولات لو بايجاز يعني في موقف
الاسلاميين
بالذات طبعا على راسي من جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين من نجيب محفوظ الحقيقه ان
جماعه الاخوان
تعاملت مع الواقع الثقافي بسماته بمعنى ان
اذا كان هناك مثلا عدد كبير جدا يقرا فنحن
يجب ان نكون على شاكلتهم يعني نقرا معهم
ونقدم نجيب محفوظ بطريقته اذا كانت هناك
اميه يعني في الازمنه الاولى التي كانت
فيها الاميه غالبه على المجتمع المصري ولا
يعرف غالبيه الشعب المصري من هو نجيب
محفوظ فهم مع الهجوم على نجيب محفوظ ومع
تشويه واتهامه دينيا هذه هي الاستراتيجيه
اما اذا كانت هناك حاله ثقافيه او رواد
ثقافي فهم مع قراءته وتقديمه
والالتفاف عليه وعلى ابداعه كما هو حاصل
مثلا في اللحظه الراهنه من هذه
الاستراتيجيه فكره ازدواجيه الداخل
والخارج يعني حين يتحدثون الى الخارج
يتحدثون بشكل ايجابي عن نجيب محفوظ ويتحدث
عنه قادتهم او زعماء الجماعه ورموزها من
المثقفين اما حين يتحدثون الى الداخل او
الى قواعدهم التحتيه يتعمدون
يعني الاساءه اليه وتشويه فهنا ازدواجيه
على اكثر من مستوى سواء في القديم او
الجديد او الداخل والخارج
محمد اسمح لي اني اسالك محطات او التحولات
في اليه تعامل التيار الاسلامي وعلى راس
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين مع نجيب محفوظ منذ
روايه اولاد حارتنا الى مثلا حصول على
جائزه نوبل الى فتره الربيع العربي كيف
تلمس هل هناك تباين في في مسار هذا تاريخي
هو هناك نسق واحد في التعامل لانهم يعني
بالتعبير البارد
جماعه متعدده الوجوب يعني هي بشكل
استراتيجيتها ثابته ان هم يعني دبل فيس
عندهم اللي بيضرب يعني هذه الاستراتيجيه
اللي بيضرب ويلاقي بالتعبير العامي يعني
دائم الحضور عند الاخوان في تعاملهم مع كل
شيء فكان مثلا سيد قطب
هو الذي يروج لفكره ان نجيب محفوظ اديب
عظيم
ويمكن الاستفاده منه في المشروع الاسلامي
لكن هنلاقي ان في المقابل رؤيه الشيوخ او
رموز الاخوان الدعويين اللي هم بيخاطبوا
القواعد العامه اللي هم بيهاجموه وكانت
المحطه الاساسيه في الهجوم اولاد حارتنا
ويمكن تثبتوها على مدار سنوات
في مرحله الهجوم او في التوظيف الهجومي
على نجيب محفوظ وظفوا روايه اولاد حارتنا
باعتبار انها يعني تسيء للاسلام وروايه
الحاديه وهكذا وده همم فضل ممتده بجائزه
نوبل هل اختلفت عاطي التيار الاسلامي
وجماعه الاخوان المسلمين مع نجيب محفوظ
ولم يختلف بمعنى انه حصل عندهم تحول جذري
لا هو زاد الاهتمام يعني هنا كان الاختلاف
يعني لانه اصبح مسار اهتمام
يعني كبير
من سواء من المنصرين او حتى من الوطن
العربي اهتمام ادبي واعلامي ضخم
رودوا لفكره مثلا يعني ان نجيب محفوظ لم
يفوز بنوب الا لهجومي على الاسلام ولم
يفوز بنوبه الا على جائزه على روايه اولاد
حارتنا تحديدا يعني هذا من هذا من الاشياء
التي اشاعوها او اشاعها جماعه الاخوان وفي
كذلك اتهام انه بسبب تاييد لاتفاقيات كام
ديفيد بين اسرائيل ومصر
فهو هنلاقي ان هم حصل يعني تضاعف
الاهتمامهم عليه وتناولهم له سواء بالسلب
او بالايجاب وفي المقابل يعني هنلاقي ان
هم برضو بداوا يركزوا على دراسته النقديه
والتعامل معه بالمنطق الاسلامي يعني
الخرطان حاضرا على يعني على امتداد الزمن
لكن تضاعف مع فوزه بجائزه نوبه طب استاذه
محمد خلينا ننتقل للحين على العلاقه التي
جمعت ما بين سيد قطب
الروائي نجيب محفوظ
هناك من يعني الكثير ما اطلعت عليه يعني
باؤكد ان نسيت قطب هو من يعني تنبا بهذه
الموهبه الجديده التي كانت انذاك
من وهو من اكتشفه من خلال كتابته لعده
مقالات في مجله الرساله
وكانت هناك علاقه ادبيه بين الرجلين فوده
لو تقول لي شو طبيعه هذا العلاقه
اولا هذه العلاقه كانت في مرحله لم يكن
الوجه الاخواني لسيد قطب قطب
ظهر او لم يكن اصلا اخوانيا فهو كان مجرد
مدرس للغه العربيه وبدا يكتب على استيحاب
بعض المقالات النقديه يعني هو كان خريج
كليه دار العلوم
وقتها مدرسه دار العلوم العليا المهم انه
يعني كاتب واديب كتب بعض المقالات
الاحتفائيه
نجيب محفوظ والحقيقه ان حوارات نجيب محفوظ
التاليه اظهرت انه لم يحتفي بهذا النقد او
لم يفترس له او لم يظهر
اهتمامه به نجيب محفوظ اهتم بالشخصيه
بابعادها الدراميه يعني بعد ذلك اتضح
اهتمام نجيب محفوظ بسيد قطب بواسطه شخصيه
دراميه او
شخصيه اسلاميه عندها تناقضات وتحولات حاده
قد يكون هناك التقاء او او زياره في
المرحله الاولى هذا امر وارد وطبيعي وليس
فيه اي مشكله لكن فكره اكتشف نجيب محفوظ
او اول من نبه له هذا غير صحيح وهذا ما
حاولت الجماعه ان تروج له في مراحل لاحقه
يعني لتدلل على قيمه سيد قطب يعني هنا
الفائده التي ارادوا ان يحققوها وهذا امر
اخر يعني في سبيل الاختطاف ان هم بيقفزوا
على نجاح نجيب محفوظ ويقول اننا نحن اول
من قدمه او عبقريه سيد قطب هي التي طرحته
او تنبات له بالحقيقه ان هناك اهتمامات
كبيره اخرى بنجيب محفوظ من بداياته يعني
ومن مشهورين او من نماذج اكثر بكثير من
سيد قطب زي مثلا سلامه موسى الذي كان
مفكرا معروفا
وكان رئيسا للتحرير لكن السيد محمد سلامه
موسى يعني هو كان احد الاساتذه الذي الذين
تاثر بهم نجيب محفوظ
بالمقابل
سيد قطب كان في ذلك الوقت يعني هو له اسم
وله حضور في الساحه الادبيه النقديه من
خلال ما يكتب من مقالات يعني في في نتكلم
في فتره الاربعينات
فيعني
ما تشوفوا التبخيس الدور سيد قطب الادبي
في هذا الاطار هو يعني شويه مثلا مبالغه
في فصل علاقه الرجلين بين يعني بينهم وبين
بعض
يعني هو ما فيش تبخيس ولا حاجه هي اولا
شيء ايجابي ومرحله اصلا لم يكن لم يكن سيد
قطب منتميا فيها اساسا للاخوان وان كان
حدث عنده تحقق فهذا يعني ليس شيئا سلبيا
ولا يحسب اصلا للاخوان لان هذه المرحله
كان يتم التعامل مع سيد قطب بوصفه يساري
يعني اقرب حتى لنفس الاتجاه بتاع سلامه
موسى
يعني هي المساله مش مفاضله لكن ما لدينا
من نصوص نقديه
لسيد قطب كتباها عن روايات نجيب محفوظ هي
مجرد للاحتفاء ولم تكن مقالات نقديه ثقيله
او ذات وزن نقدي كبير ومهم مكان هو من عرف
بالقارئ العربي بنجيب محفوظ من خلال هذه
المقالات هو سيد قطب الكلام ده حصل
يعني سافروا لامريكا حصل في سنه 49 48 او
هو السفر في السنه 51 ورجع في نفس العام
يعني بعد تسع شهور او حاجه زي كده اقل من
عام يعني
لم يكن اصلا سيد قطب شخصيه زائعه ومشهوره
الى هذا الحد حتى يعرف بنجيب محفوظ
وبالمناسبه السيد محمد هو كان عنده علاقه
يعني صح انه جيل اخر وكان يعني شابا لكنه
كان له علاقه مع العقاد مع التوفيق الحكيم
مع طه حسين يعني
ما نقدر اننا نصفه انه مجرد استاذ لغه
عربيه هو كان يحضر صالون العقاد لكنه لم
يكن كبيرا ومشهورا وزائعا وله مقالات
عديده او كتب عديده يعني حتى الكتاب اللي
اصله كتاب يعني
محدود
ويعني غير رائد فكريا يعني هي المساله مش
تقليل على الاطلاق تمام يعني
هي المساله لان هو
ليس تنصلا من الاخوان لانه لم يكن اخوانيا
اصلا يعني
قلنا ان هو كان عبقريا او كتب نقدا مهما
فهذا لا يحسن للاخوان لكن الفكره احنا
بنتعامل بشكل موضوعي مع هذه الفتره مع
يعني وزن وحجم كل شخصيه وبالمناسبه اريد
ان اؤكد على نقطه نجيب محفوظ نفسه لم يكن
بوزنه المعروف بعد ذلك يعني هو كان مجرد
شاب طموح كتب عدد من الروايات التاريخيه
في هذا الوقت
لم يكن قد وصل لان يكون مثلا الاديب الاهم
او الابرز وكان معه عدد كبير جدا من
الادباء الاخرين زي عادل كامل مثلا الذي
كان مجيلا له ولم يكن يقل عنه موهبه لكنه
لم يستمر نجيب محفوظ نفسه في هذا الزمن لم
يكن هو الشخصيه البارزه او هو الاديب
الابرز همم يعني كما حدث السنوات اللاحقه
وكان له همم يعني مجايلون او زملاء او
رفقاء لا يقلون عنه وعلى سبيل المثال عادل
كامل
لم يكن الا مدرج شاب كتب عدد من الروايات
التاريخيه الجيده والمبشره ومهمه لكنه
اكتمل كمشروع بعد ذلك يعني
المساله ليست تقليل ولا ترخيص من قدر نقض
اسمح لي السيد محمد نجيب محفوظ كان كان
سجل في مذكراته فيما يتعلق بسيد قطب وتطرق
الى علاقته او رايه بسيد قطب ومن بين
مجالها برغم الخلافه الفكري بيني وبين قط
فانني كنت اعتبره حتى اليوم الاخير من
عمره صديقا وناقدا ادبيا كبيرا كان له فضل
السبق في الكتابه عني ولفت الانظار الي في
وقت تجاهلني نقاد الاخرون فهذا يعني من
نجيب محفوظ نفسه انه يؤكد يعني اللي يدور
سيد قطب في هالموضوع امر طبيعي ومتصل مع
ذكريات يعني كاتب كان يعني يرى مرحله
الاولى
بموضوعيه وبامانه يعني اكيد محفوظ قاعد
بهذا التصريح في سيرته التي قالها او
املاها على رجاء النقاش يعني في عمر متاخر
فكان
مرحله شبابه
ويشعر بالامتنان
للشاب او لناقد كان مجيلا له او قريب من
سنه وكتب عنه
وكانوا على فكره في قريبين من العمر يعني
مفيش فارق كبير في
السن بينهما فهذا امر طبيعي ويتصف كمان مع
سماتي
وسمات الانسان يعني الذي يجب ان يكون
متسقا مع مبادئه ومع ما يكتب ومع افكاره
التي يضمنها في كتاباته والاديب دائما ما
تكون نظرته مختلفه عن
يعني القانون او حتى الحكومات او الانظمه
فامر طبيعي ان يكون قد رااه بهذا
الامتنان او بهذا التقدير لكونه
دون الاخرين او في وقت تجاهله فيه
الاخرون وده يؤكد ما ذكرت من كون نجيب
محفوظ لم يكن مشهورا ولم يكن قد يعني بزغ
نجمه او كتب عنه المسيح
الكاتب عطيه عامر ذكر بان هو من رشح نجيب
محفوظ لجائزه نوبل واحنا نشوف يعني كل
فتره تطلع يعني تقارير وتطلع تصريحات
منرشح نجيب محفوظ
لجائزه نوبل فكيف تشوف
تصريحها حتى انه ظهرت تصريحات تقول ان
اسرائيل هي من رشحت نجيب محفوظ لجائزه
نوبل اولا هذا الامر كان في وقت حكم
الاخوان كان في مارس 2012 في مكتب الاستاذ
صلاح عيسى رئيس تحرير جريده القاهره
عليهم
الدكتور عطيه عامر من السويد يعني بشكل
مفاجئ وهو في عمر التسعين ومعه مذكراته
الشخصيه التي
املاها على شخص اخر يعني هو لم يكن يكتب
في هذا السن وقال او قدم نفسه بان لديه
يعني شهاده شامله وواسعه للادب
وبالتالي لشخصيه الادب والثقافه في الوطن
العربي وركز على شخصيه نجيب محفوظ تمام
هذه الجلسه التي كانت في حكم الاخوان طرح
السيناريوين يعني
الاحتمالات اللباني يعني راجا وزاعه كان
اصلهما في هذه الجلسه التي بداها او كانت
نقطه البدايه فيها من عند عطيه عامر في
مكتب الاستاذ صلاح عيسى في مارس 2012 يعني
في وقت حكم الاخوان الاخوان
ان يحاصروا المثقف العربي بهذين
الاحتمالين اللي هو ايه يعني قللنا ما كتب
الصحفي الاستاذ محمد الشماع الذي ادلى له
عطيه عامر بهذه التصريحات ثم منحه هذه
المذكرات التي كانوا يفترض ان تنشر
للدكتور عطيه عامر لو حللنا وتابعنا كل
هذه التفاصيل سنجد انها فيها اضطرابات
وفيها عمد لانه هو طرح الاحتمالين في نفس
الجلسه هو نفس الشخص
طرح الاحتمال احتمال ايه ان هو عطيه عامر
الذي ساعد نجيب محفوظ على الفوز بنوبه او
كان السبب الاساسي يعني هو مش احد الاسباب
حتى لم يطرحها بهذه الكيفيه انما هو طرح
نفسه بوصف السبب الاساسي او هو
يعني السبب الاوحد ل فوز نجيب محفوظ بنوب
او الاحتمال الثاني بقى اللي بيحكيه برده
في سياق كده ملتبس ومرتبك وغريب
وتم انكاره
والتدارك عليه من الشخصيات اللي ذكرها وهو
ايه بقى اني الاستاذ نجيب محفوظ ذكر ان
اول من هن كان
مناحم بيجن تمام
اني لما الاستاذ محمد الشماع تحقق او بحث
في هذا الامر يعني هو نشر هذه التصريحات
في ذلك الوقت في جريده القاهره وكان يفترض
طلقه اهتمام كبير جدا من المصريين لكن
كانت الاجواء السياسيه وقتها صعبه فما
كانش في تركيز كبير على هذا الامر المهم
اني هو نسب الكلام لمين للاستاذ يوسف
القعيد يعني ما قالش ان محفوظ هو الذي قال
عطيه عامر لا ده في وسيط اللي هو مين
الاستاذ يوسف القعيد والاستاذ يوسف القعيد
مازال حيا الان ربنا يدي له الصحه نفى هذا
الكلام وقال انه ليس له علاقه
الدكتور عطيه عامر ولم يستطيع ابدا ولم
يسمع هذا الكلام من الاستاذ نجيب محفوظ
وهي روايه اصلا غريبه يعني هو نفسه الذي
يروج لهذين الاحتمالين اما ان يكون
اسرائيل هي التي ساعدت نجيب محفوظ على
الفوز بنوبل او جماعه الاخوان بالضبط
وهنا نقطه مهمه جدا اني
الدكتور عطيه عامر في نفس هذه الجلسه وهو
امتدح سيد قطب يعني كشف او اظهر
انتماءاته او بعض انتماءاته يعني فاحنا
بنضع فكره السياق والمرحله التاريخيه الذي
جاء فيها الى مصر وهو في هذه في هذه السن
المتقدمه مع امتداءه
لسيد قطب مع فكره ان هو نفسه صاحب
الاحتمال الثاني اسرائيل فهكذا نكون في
النهايه محاصرين بهذين الاحتمالين طب
استاد محمد
هل كانت هناك اي محاولات للاستماله نجيب
محفوظ من قبل جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
هناك يعني اراء
وحوادث تؤكد هذه المحاوله
وبخاصه من خلال ابن اخته
الاستاذ جمال النهري الذي كان عضوا في
جماعه الاخوان بل كان عضوا في الجناح
المسلح وهو
عادل النهري الاثنان كان متهمين في قضايا
مهمه وخطيره
لتنظيم الاخوان وتم اعتقالهم اكثر من مره
ويعني هما شخصيتان ليست بحاجه الى ادله
على انتمائهم يعني الاخوان يعني تحدثوا
عنهم وهم تحدثوا عن انتمائهم بالصوت صوره
وتحدثوا عن تاريخهم فانتماء هذه الشخصيات
معروف لكن في مراسلات
لجمال النهري بالتحديد الذي كان مهتم
بخاله بناء على توصيه من من من سيد قطب
حين الفقاه في مستشفى السجن واوصاه بخاله
وقال له ان هو اديب كبير وممكن ان هو يفيد
الدعوه الاسلاميه يعني هنا التقط او يعني
تقابل او حصل اجتماع
للخال مع
التصور الاخواني بقى الذي يمثله سيد قطب
تطور الاخواني الناعم
المستثمر لموهبه
فكانت هذه المراسلات تدور يعني في اطار
هذه الاستماع بشكل هذا الواضح بان يتم
استثمار نجيب نجيب محفوظ في اطار الادب
الاسلامي نعم
الاستاذ جمال النهري ذكر ان كان في
مخاطبات بينه وبين خاله يعني هو كان في
الخارج يعمل لبعض صحف الاخوانيه او ذات
الانتماء هو كان بالكويت جلس بعد 67 انتقل
الى بعد ما خرج من السجن من خلال توسط
شقيقه حمزه الذي كان له علاقات كبيره
وقريبه مع عبد الحكيم عامر انذاك
واستطاع ان يخرج بعد فتره بسيطه والذهب
الى الكويت بواسطه من منير الدله القيادي
وعضو الارشاد في جماعه الاخوان وهو كان
مزامله في السجن وفي
نفس فتره سيد قطب وبعدها انتقل الى
السعوديه وعمل يعني بواسطتهم ايضا في
مركز او هيئه البحوث الاسلاميه
بالضبط هو
تم
مراسله خاله او جرت مراسلات بينهم وارسل
له يعني بعض الهدايا زي مثلا يعني بعض
الاطعمه التي المحببه او الاشياء الخاصه
بمرض السكر لما عرف ان هو كان قد مرض
بالسكر اللي هو خالو نجيب محفور هذه
المراسلات دارت بحسب بعض المواقع التي
نشرتها وبحسب شهاده
جمال النهر نفسه في هذا الاطار اللي هو ان
لابد الابداع ان يكون له وجه
الاسلامي
يعني الحث على فكره النهضه
الاسلاميه واستعاده
او او الاستنهاض الدوله الاسلاميه مره
اخرى ونجيب محفوظ راى هذا في اطار الحلم
بدوله المثاليه يعني بعيدا عن الايدولوجيا
المغلقه او بعيدا عن النظره العدائيه
وربما يمكننا قراءتها او تفسيرها في
لحظتها هذه بانه اتعمل تعامل انساني يعني
بعيدا عن الثقافه هذا ابن اخته الغائب
ويترسم لابد ان يكون رفيقا معه او يكون
بسمته الادبي والاحسان يعني يبتعد عن
الصدمات وهكذا طب استاذ محمد اسمح لي اننا
نسمع مع بعض هذا المقطع للدكتور والنقد
الادبي الاستاذ محمد حسن عبد الله وهو
يتحدث عن لقاء بجمال النهري وهو ابن اخت
نجيب محفوظ ويتكلم عن ماذا طلب منه وابغى
اسمع تعليقك على هذا الموضوع
حدث اني واحد قريبه او زعم انه قريبه وقال
لي احنا عاوزين نعمل دراسات وكان رئيس
تحرير مجله في الكويت وكنت انا في ذلك
مدرس يعني حتى لما استاذ مساعد مدرس في
كليه الاعداب وقال لي عاوزين مقالات عن
الاسلام في ادب نجيب محفوظ قلت له ما فيش
حاجه اسمها الاسلام ده
يعني حاول
ما فيش حاجه اسمها الاسلام لكن ممكن اقول
الاسلاميه والروحيه يعني الجانب الاخلاقي
الجانب الاخلاقي الجانب الامن في عالم اخر
او عالم اكثر ترتيبا
او اخلاقا في ادب نجيب محفو
ظ يعني الحته الحلم المثالي
يعني بس الاسلاميين ما بيحبوش كلمه
الروحيه دي ما ليش دعوه بالاسلاميين انا
ينفع قال ينفع السيد محمد بعد ما سمعنا
المقطع وقبل ما اسمع ردك على ما جاء فيه
كان موقع اخوان ويكيبيديا يعني تتكلموا هو
تحدثوا في اطار سردهم لسيره جمال النهري
وذكروا بان
انا كان من الجميل
ولطيف انا عاد الاستاذ سيد قطب للاستاذ
جمال تعريف نجيب محفوظ خالي الاخير وقال
له لو قدر لك ان تخرج سترى نجيب محفوظ
اعظم اديب في مصر وربما في العالم ونسق
ونصح بلقاء الاستاذ نجيب محفوظ والتعرف
عليه عن قرب والتعلم منه وايضا في المقطع
اللي احنا استمعنا اليه هو ذكر قال انه مش
راح يرضي الاسلاميين يعني قد يكون المقصود
هنا جمهور وقراء مجلات البلاغ اللي هي
تصدر في الكويت وهو ايضا كان يعمل في
ويكتب لمجله المجتمع الكويتيه فكان
حديثهم هنا عن الجمهور الاسلامي انه ما
راح يقبل
مثل هذا الاسم لهذا الكتاب
نعم يعني هنا نفهم
يعني عدد من الاشياء اول شيء قبل قبل
الاستاذ محمد ما تعطيني في هذا الاطار
حدثني عن هذا الكتاب الذي طلب
جمال النهري من الناقد الادبي هو لم يطلب
كتابه الكتاب لان الكتاب كان مشروع مستقل
بعد ذلك يعني الكتاب
في مرحله بعد ذلك يعني بحسب شهاده الدكتور
محمد حسن عبد الله التي تكررت في اكثر من
موضع عن هذا
الاستكتاب او الامر او الطلب
للكتابه الذي جاء من
جمال النهري هو كتابه مقالات يعني عدد من
المقالات التي تقدم الرؤيه الاسلاميه في
ادب نجيب محفوظ او تطرح نجيب محفوظ بطرح
اسلامي او من وجهه نظر اسلاميه او من
منظور اسلامي وهكذا نعرف ان هذا كان بشكل
عملي يعني
قد تحقق او حدث من وقت مبكر يعني هم فكروا
في هذا الاختطاف او التعامل الاسلامي مع
نجيب محفوظ من وقت مبكر لكن اعتراضه وجه
اعتراضه
اني هم يريدون الرؤيه الاسلاميه بشكل
مباشر يعني لا تحتاج الى تاويل او
بمنظورنا صعب يعني او بحسب فهم جمال النهر
نفسه الذي يعني في قراءته وتقديري انا
الشخصي لم يكن له علاقه كبيره بالادب يعني
هو كان رجل تنظيميا
يعني صاحب فكر جهادي باعتبار في المراحل
الاولى للجناح المسلح واتهامه في عدد من
القضايا الخطيره فهو لم يكن ذا اهتمام
اصلا بالادب هو جمال النهري وبال كان يريد
الرؤيه الاسلاميه بشكل مباشر وهنلاحظ برده
امر اخر وهو ان جمال النهري
بتصريحه هو نفسه لم يكن يحب الدعنه دي
بمحفوظ او رواياته يعني في شبابه برغم ان
نجيب محفوظ خاله وكان يهدي بعض اعمال
لوالدته باعتبارها اخت نجيب محفوظ لم يكن
يهتم
بالابداع او بالروايه ويرى ان هذه الاشياء
امور سخيفه الى ان حدث هذا اللقاء الذي
يتحدث عنه بينه وبين سيد قطب ومن هنا حدث
التحول لكن مهم جدا ان احنا نشير لاني هذا
الكلام الذي قيل او ذكره موقع اخوانه
ويكيبيديا او ذكره الاخوان عموما عن سيد
قطب كان بعد فوزن نجيب محفوظ بنوبل يعني
هذا الكلام لم يخرج للعلن او يذكر ويفرح
به الا بعد فوز نجيب محفوظ بنوبل يعني في
مراحل متاخره في الثمانينات وفي التسعينات
يعني هذا اللقاء المصور الذي يدلي فيه
جمال النهري بهذه الشهاده كان في مرحله
محمد
الناقد الادبي ام جمال
الاثنين الحقيقه لكن اللقاء اللقاء بتاع
الدكتور محمد حسن عبد الله مع جمال النهري
كان زمنه محدد ومحسوم بزمن المقالات
الاولى التي نشرها الدكتور محمد حسن عبد
الله عن الاسلاميه والروحيه في ادب نجيب
محفوظ طبعا هو الكتاب الاسلاميه والروحيه
كان طبع الاولى كانت في عام 1972 بعد بعد
سنوات من وصول جمال النهري للكويت بالضبط
بعد سنوات لكن قبل الكتاب كان في مقالات
يعني استنادا لما ذكر الدكتور محمد حسن
عبد الله
ان جمال النهري لم ينشر الا عدد معين من
المقالات
ثم توقف عن النشر لكن الدكتور محمد حسن
عبد الله اكمل مشروعه بانفصال عن هذا
التكليف او هذا الطلب او الاستكتاب يعني
يبدو ان جمال النهري كان يريد كتابه
اسلاميه مباشره بدليل الاختلاف الذي حدث
بينهما او الاختلاف في الراي وتصريح
الدكتور السيد عبد الله بان جمال النهري
قال له ان فكره الروحيه لن ترضي
الاسلاميين يعني هو يريد رؤيه اسلاميه
مباشره او تفسير اسلامي مباشر لادب نجيب
محفوظ وحين لم يتحقق هذا الغرض
بشكل واضح يعني كف نشر او توقف عن نشر هذه
المقالات لكن الدكتور محمد حسن عبد الله
اكمل مشروعها او قراءته النقديه وصدر هذا
الكتاب الاسلاميه والروحيه بانفصال عن
تكليف او طلب جمال النهر نفسه طب استاذ
محمد حضرتك ما تشوف ان هذه يعني
يعني من يشاهدونه ويستمعوا الينا يقول لك
ان هذه الرغبه شخصيه من جمال النهري انه
هو طبعا سيد احتفى امامه بنجيب محفوظ وان
هذا خاله وانه عليه ان يتعرف عليه وعلى
ادبه وكذا تحمس لا من خلال تزكيه سيد قطب
لخالها يعني ليش احنا نستبعد الجانب
الشخصي لدى جمال نهري وايضا كان هناك في
ديك الفتره
كتابات واساءات كثيره لنجيب محفوظ فهو
يعني يبقى خاله ويبقى اشياء تكون ايجابيه
يتم التسليط الضوء عليها تمام احنا لا
نستبعد الفردي ولا نستبعد الجماعي انا في
تصوري هذه اللحظه
اتحدت فيها الرؤيتان او الغردان او اهداف
جمال النهري بشكل
بصورته او بصفته الفرديه وبعلاقته الفرديه
مع الهدف الجماعي لاني حين يعني ننظر لما
سعي جمال النهري لابد ان ننظر اليها في
اطار رؤيه سيد قطب
وتعريف وسيد قطب هو الذي نبا وهو رمزي
اخواني يعني هو الذي نبه
جمال النهري لقيمه خاله
ولتوظيف الاسلامي بالتحديد لابداع
نجيب محفوظ فهنا يعني اذا كنا نريد ان نضع
في اعتبارنا البعد الفردي او الرغبه
الفرديه من جمال النهري فبالتالي برضو يجب
لا نستبعد
الهدف الجماعي او الرغبه الجامعي يمكن ان
نقول انه انها لحظه التحم فيها
الغرضان او الرؤيه ثاني طب هل التقى نجيب
محفوظ بحسن البنا هل حدث اي لقاء بينهم او
محاولات لترتيب لقاء الحياه كل ما يذكر
انه لم يعني
نجيب محفوظ لم يكن في هذه المرحله حتى
مقتل حسن البنا في 48 لم يكن نجما او لم
يكن اكثر من مجرد كاتب
ادبي طموح وكاتب روائي طموح وهنلاحظ اني
في البدايه او في المراحل الاولى
الاخوان بالاساس استراتيجيتهم لا يهتمون
بالادب بالعكس يحرمون الروايه ويرون انها
من باب الاختلاط والكذب والتنسيق لانها
تتعارض مع المرويات الشفهيه الدينيه ويرون
انها يعني قد تصل الى حد الطعن في مروءه
الانسان او في صدق الرجل
ويعني شرفه لانه يختلق حكايات من عنده
فهذه البدايات كانت بعيده عن فكره التوظيف
المباشر الا في اشاره سيد قطب فقط وهو هنا
يتعامل بوصفه او بوجهه الابداعي والادبي
او الفكري اللي هو يقدم فرحا مستنيرا يعني
اسمح لي اني اسالك في هذا الاطار كان اشر
وحسب ما ذكر عن
الاديب نجيب محفوظ الى ان يقول يعني في
مذكرات لان الزميل والصديق الراحل عبد
الحميد جوده السحار ممن يميلون الى
تاريخيه الاخوان المسلمين وجلساتهم وسمرهم
فدعاني اكثر للمره لمقابله مرشدهم الشيخ
حسن البنا فرفضت الدعوه بكل اصرار الان
تغيرت الدنيا واصبحت هذه التيارات على
درجه كبيره من الخطر واصبح الفساد هو الاب
الشرعي لقوتها انهم يستولون على الجماعات
والنقابات هنا يمكن ان نلبس نقطه التقاء
الاولى بين الاخوان ونجيب محفوظ لكن
الاخوان بعمومهم وليس وليس حسن البنا تمام
يعني في قراءه الشخصيه وقراءه التاريخيه
لهذه الاشياء ان
نقطه الاتصال الاولى بين جماعه الاخوان
ونجيب محفوظ كانت عبر عائله الصحار
والاهداف
الاخوانيه كما ذكرت لحضرتك معروفه فيما
يتصل
النشر والتثقيف كان امرا مهما ومن اساسيات
بناء جماعه الاخوان يعني فكره ان يكون لهم
الزراعه الاعلامي والثقافي والفكري
وتغيير المجتمع
واجتياح المجتمع بالافكار الاخوانيه من
خلال المطبوعات والكتب ودور النشر وهذه
الاشياء يعني كانت مؤسسه ومتجذره في تكوين
الاخوان منذ البدايه
بهذا السؤال كان في احنا تحدثنا طبعا عن
الكتاب الروحانيات اسلاميه في ادب نجيب
محفوظ
هل هذه تعتبر اول كتابات
بخصوص التركيز على ما يعرف بالفكره
الاسلاميه في ادب نجيب محفوظ ام ان كان
هناك خط متصل لعدد من الكتابات نتكلم في
ذيك الفتره ما هو عمل فردي وجهد فردي
وانتهى الحياه ان في عدد كبير جدا من
الاعمال والمقالات
وكم ما كتب من منظور اخواني عن نجيب محفوظ
يعني كبير جدا بين الكتب
والمقالات في ديك الفتره في نفس التزامنا
مع هذا الكتاب لاني ابي اربطه اذا هناك
توجه حزبي تنظيمي فيما ذكره جمال النهري
او لا او انه تصرف فردي شخصي
الحقيقه انا بس اريد اؤكد على نقطه اني
كتابه الدكتور محمد حسن عبد الله ليست
كتابه اخوانيه يعني للانصار الحق وهو نفسه
يعني تحدث عن اختلاف بين رؤيتي ورؤيه جمال
النهري فهو يمكن انه كان شاهد على واقعه
لكنه لم يكن ضمن هذا المشروع الاخواني
يعني هو الى المكونات الاسلاميه والجوانب
الروحيه ده حقيقي لكن لم يكن الحقيقه ضمن
هذا المشروع النقدي الاخواني الذي اشتغل
على ادب نجيب محفوظ
وقت مبكر نعم حدث اهتمام والتفات كبير
لادب نجيب محفوظ قد لا يكون من هذه النقطه
في السبعينات لكن حدث بعد ذلك في
الثمانينات والتسعينات يعني مقالات كثيره
كتبت عن الشخصيه الاسلاميه او شخصيه
المتدين طيب استاذ يعطيك الف عافيه وشكره
مشاركتك معنا وشكرا لك كل هذه المعلومات
واسمح لي ان اختم هنا عقود طويله لا تزال
تفصل بين مشهدين متفارقين الاول اسم نجيب
محفوظ يعتلي منصه جائزه للادب والثاني
لحظات قطب الاخيره وهو في طريقه الى منصه
الاعدام لاتهامه بتدبير اعمال ارهابيه
لقلب نظام الحكم بين من اصبح قطب الروايه
العربيه وبين من ارتدى بدله الحمراء بين
من كان لمريديه وتلامذته طريقا ورافدا
للابداع الادبي والثقافي والانساني وبين
من مهد لاجيال في ساحات الموت الجهادي
والتكفير والهجره هذا جماعاته وانا هدى
الصالح
[موسيقى]